The jogan Experience Florida is it's the
craziest place it's awesome it's crazier
than Texas it's it's next level crazy
like when when Texas Falls I I will have
to move to Florida Simone's living in
Central Florida which is like not even
big city it's all weird farmers and
people moving slowly really like Tampa
like in between Tampa Orlando in between
the move is to live in the Everglades if
you can gee that's the move those are
wild people just sitting on a stupid the
shoo if you if you have to move to if
there's a way to live as close to the
Everglades as is legally possible that's
where you should live you should live on
top of the the literal literal serpents
and
dinosaurs that occupy the center of the
dick of the
country Montana gets too cold and you
can die outside and there's no one there
you manage the monsters least populated
state but if you want to have fun if you
really want to have fun you got to be be
in Mortal danger almost every day New
York this isor Mortal danger almost
every day this is what you do when all
goes south you you get a place that's
surrounded by alligators and
Croc giant pythons but those gators end
up in your pool [__] and it's 114
degrees in the summer and you think you
might run out of water and die hold on
have you guys watched this guy we've
talked about this guy before which guy
this is the guy that Kim Conan brought
up that I couldn't find fishing fishing
with Garrett he's so good dude he calls
them swamp puppies oh yeah yeah yeah we
did we had uh python cowboy on the
podcast we talked about like finding
pythons in uh Florida nuts man he's got
dogs now and the dogs are
trained python Cowboy it does it does
that's you know
who you know who python Cowboy's
nickname is who what Michelle
Obama should see it coming big mik not
bad not bad not bad that's pretty good
that's pretty good there something about
python that's a great word python do you
know there's a half a million of them
estimated in the Everglades that's what
that guy does Garrett oh yeah he goes
around and grabs pythons all shitload of
those dudes shitload of those dudes
Pauls they they're shooting Iguanas
Iguanas are everywhere Florida Is
Amazing by the way missed they have a
shoot on site order for Nile crocodiles
in the Everglades yeah they're like
crocodil to apparently no no it's mostly
alligators but they've spotted African
Nile crocodile the ones that eat
zebras neighborhood the ones that eat
people they eat everything they eat
everything and they think there might be
a breeding population in the every can't
be we got to kill them it's amazing the
same [__] that happened with Pythons
will happen with crocodiles if they get
a breeding population start going us
over what they are it's like
Marshall Marshall's an alligator a
crocodile is my dog Frank do you
remember Frank the Pitbull Frank anim
that that was he was a psycho like he
was it was he was a dog of he growl at
me and I'd be like d Jo [__] get him
out of here he just like he like had to
run [__] like he he had a it was a weird
thing he was a good dog but he like he
had over he never did anything he just
sit there go if he thought you were a
[__] fcking [__] and I'm like Joe get
him away from thought you were nervous
he would corner you he just didn't trust
people in the house he was a he was a
crazy dog but that's what a crocodile's
like yeah it's a totally different
animal than an alligator there's a video
of this tank filled with alligators and
crocodiles and they start feeding the
alligators and the crocodiles and the
crocodiles just stomp on the alligators
and get to the food W they get to the
food real quick Joe's fired up it's a
totally different thing when you watch
them you go oh they they evolved
differently they evolved with lions they
evolved with zebras and wilderbeast and
water buffal and [__] n crocodiles are
like five times the size of a they get
[__] watch so watch this this dude's
feeding them
wow
W so the story is they put Moses's
casket in that a little basket with a
baby and thre it in there get out of
here oh my God slap it on
the this kid needs some CarX oh my God
that's scary all right let's see where
the shark is bro those are all real live
dinosaurs real live ancient creatures
that didn't need to evolve they they had
a good mixture of survival and numbers
what
[Music]
I thought we being racist all right I
take it back this is my favorite when
this this Croc bites this other Croc's
leg off and the other one doesn't even
Flinch and then he swallows it watch
this go go what the [__] yeah bro that's
what's in the [__]
Everglades some of those [__]
are in the Everglades they spotted see
if you can find that cuz I I know we
might have talked about this before but
if those things get to a breeding
population they just dominate The
Everglades it's not like an alligator
where it's okay to walk across a golf
course that thing will [__] you up it
will chase you if it's hungry it'll
chase you you ever hear uh real real
talk by R
Kelly there's literally already a clip
with 2.8 million views jile crocodil
area Joe
Rogan I can't help myself that's what
happens my type just ever I'm [__]
terrified of that if it's true you know
he's not scared of and crocodiles but
don't Google that Google whether or not
cats we all know they were destroyed by
P oh that's just Cay pull those
videos they'll fight alligator Jags they
slap them in the face it works well no
Jaguars eat them but no like a house cat
versus an aligator house cat will still
sit there and be like yeah [__]
occasionally pull it upas that's all
they know how to do they don't know this
dangerous like dogs are the best they
bark at them but like you're just
sitting there and they come up to the
shore and just go one of my one of my
Favorite Things me and soda ever joked
about the first like right when me and
soda met it was our favorite thing here
we go this is a regular [__] it worked
that's also [__] ass little alligator
now there's some big ones there's some
big ones big I was just [__] away oh
my God this that's so crazy look at that
monster that's a cute cat look at the
face on that thing Jesus Christ imagine
that looking at you imagine you're naked
and your dick is like 2 feet away from
that thing how much fear would would be
going through your mind and they're both
like like what do we do here imagine
you're on the shore I want that I want
you to picture this you're on the shore
and you're just banging your wife and
you didn't realize oh yeah that that
thing was right there you look over and
you're like holy [__] they man they put
a bunch of food on the they set that up
they put a bunch of food down there but
the cat's not scared at all no why won
to go for the
cat it do move toward [__] you too then
cats are to too fast for that they're
very fast you see cat there's a thing
cat jumping at cucumbers hold on hold on
oh those are great of
control they go
nuts cat uh cats have like faster
reflexes than snakes oh so it's like
those are great when it comes close to
it the cat like goes away and is like
but you know what my favorite videos
[Music]
are you know what my favorite videos
with cats are is crows influencing them
to fight each other yeah I've seen that
over so smart dude crows are smart like
a kid they're smart like a human kid
like a
six-year-old Punk no they [__] with tou
the te one cat and they fly over and
tease the other cat and the cats are
opposite rooftops they start meowing
each
other the crows are up on a wire look at
these idiots yeah it's pretty great and
then they [__] leap over and fight
each other and the crow is watching and
he follows them the entire time
HS it's another one this a different one
this is totally different crow like
instant gay cats man really yeah so
these two cats are facing off with each
other the crows like fight [__] come on
fight [__] it's acial War they get
close enough so that they annoy the cat
whoa but this is like my see look they
watch they like look at this [__] this
is amazing man crows are good crows like
it wow it's like when people like
watching people fight yeah crows are
enjoying this this is like you and
Cormier doing the
commentary it really is look at this is
hilarious crows are so [__] smart man
it [__] up this whole idea that the
only way you could be smart is if you
have a big brain crows [__] that up yeah
because they fig this is my favorite
video this Crow comes over and he just
subtly [__] with his cat and then he
flies over to the other side and he
flies back and forth and he keeps
[__] with these cats he gets close
enough to irritate them and he pecks at
their asses and
[__] look he gets behind them he gets
behind him he [__] with him look at him
chance these are the same two cats is it
I they
look no they fight this guy knows about
imagine they just been doing this for
weeks the [__] Don King of
cat only only in Mumbai look at this
they they do look similar don't
they they go out they go off the
[__] look the crow follows him down
he still [__] with get him get him he
called you a homo white he's becking at
them dude he's watching bro they go down
the stairs in
oneis bro these these cats are getting
after
it